what is going on everybody welcome to
the 14th Python with NLT K for natural
language processing tutorial video in
this video we're going to be talking
about pickle or how to save basically
you're trained algorithm so every time
you want to use your trained algorithm
you don't have to go through and retrain
it so the training process for this
algorithm actually this specific
algorithm the training process is not
that slow the longest part of the the
process is probably just the loading in
of the documents but that said there's
going to be times where you you maybe
you're writing you've got one algorithm
or down the road we're actually going to
have many algorithms and we're going to
use a voting process on those algorithms
to decide what the decision is amongst
all of the algos and it adds up pretty
quickly to train each algorithm
especially if you're doing the same
training set every single time why not
save it so pickle is a way that we can
actually save Python objects so then we
can load in those objects and it's
actually extremely powerful so anyway
let's just go ahead and hop in and show
a quick example of using pickles so
first of all to use it we need to import
it and it's just pickle like the food so
import pickle and then what we'll do is
near the bottom just somewhere after we
do this part you know we can save the
classifier by doing something like we
can first of all we'll say save
underscore classifier is going to eat
will open and then we'll save it as some
sort of file name but we'll call it
naive Bayes dot pickle and we want to
open this with the intention to W B
which is right in bytes if you're on
Python 2 this won't matter but it for
Python 3 and beyond which you should be
on anyways this you have to write it as
bytes so anyway so there's that and then
we'll do pickle
dump what do we want to dump we
want to dump this classifier right the
thing that we trained to this word
classifier what do we want to dump where
do we want to dump it to save underscore
classifier okay
then of course as usual classifier The
Closer save classifier up close will
close that file good so let's go ahead
and save and run that and while we're
waiting let's go over here but we save
that naivebayes pickle all the last one
I did yes here it is we'll wait on this
one it come on okay so we had a 69%
accuracy and we've saved it now to this
naive Bayes dot pickle file alrighty so
we've got that saved now what we could
do is instead of saving the classifier
let's just comment that part out and
then here where we have we're loading in
this classifier instead of having it be
the training what we can do is something
like this so we can say whoops where am
i their classifier underscore effort
file basically equals open and it's the
same file naive Bayes dot pickle we want
to open it with the intention to read in
bytes again because of Python 3s
differentiation between bytes and
streams then we're going to say
classifier equals pickled load what do
we want to load classifier F and then of
course classifier close and actually its
classifier F dot close cool
all right soon run that um actually uh
sorry let's comment this out even though
it'll redefined it anyways
we'll just comment it out to show that
our our magical trick is actually
working here with pickle um so we might
have a separate percentage accuracy who
this one was actually really bad haha I
assure you this might actually still be
bags the one that we've said let's see
are we saving every time now sure hope
they won't get 56
there we go 67 whew like I said this
kind of unreliability in accuracy
numbers you know the 50 as you saw
earlier we got an 89 percent and now on
the same algorithm we got a 56 percent
like this is horrible I'll show you
later on how we can use this voting
process to get at least a stable uh
accuracy percent and then as we go on
we'll kind of dig into this accuracy and
kind of see if we can figure out what's
causing this much volatility and our
accuracy but anyways that was just a
quick tutorial on saving the classifier
says you might want to tweak things and
maybe you can save like you you might
tweak things a little bit maybe you want
to add more words or something like that
and you want to save that classifier
this is how you can do it you can save
it actually you could pickle this entire
document you could have pickled
everything here you could you know make
a class out of this basically and pickle
that and um and then you wouldn't have
to run this every time because as you
add on top of this and do more analysis
it's only going to take more and more
time every time you run it so it makes a
lot of sense to pickle it so anyways
that's pickling just a real quick
example with this although pickle is
extremely useful this is not an NL TK
thing this is actually pretty your
standard library so definitely check out
pickle think about using it I know that
I definitely under use pickle in my time
I didn't really think about looking into
it it's a lot more useful than it is so
that I thought it was a lot more useful
than do this anyway that's it for this
tutorial if you have any questions or
comments please feel free to leave them
below otherwise as always thanks for
watching thanks for all
sport the subscriptions until next time